all right a Roxy
Roxy where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I'm from a town called
Emily City Michigan it's about an hour
north of Detroit Michigan
tell me about your family growing up
my family growing up we were lower
middle class
um
my father was a very Headstrong
Italian-American man
um who wound up getting Ms when he was
in his early 30s which is how old I am
now and so at that point my mother was
the one to actually
take care of us
and growing up there it just for me
I felt very uninspired
you know the small town Michigan life
wasn't so much for me although it is for
other people I I saw myself seeking more
kind of felt like a little bit of the
black sheep of the family
and wind up moving to New Orleans when I
was in my adulthood
and really found myself there New
Orleans is a very different city isn't
it than anywhere else in in the world
yes absolutely
it's almost like uh
seems like time stood still a little bit
here I really do think so I do think so
I mean everybody knows it for you know
the New Orleans jazz music and the
architecture of course
um so I I found myself being very drawn
to that at a really young age and I
think a lot of that had to do with also
that I I didn't feel like I belonged
where I grew up so I would watch
the Travel Channel find out about other
countries or other cities and uh became
very in tune to like the vampire
Chronicles and all of that so whatever
you want to call it at a very young age
it really drew me to here and I knew
that at some point in my life I would
wind up here and certainly I did yeah
see it's a little bit like San Francisco
or Los Angeles where people come from
wherever the Midwest or anywhere and
become a new version of themselves
absolutely and I don't even know if it's
a new version or if it's just who they
had always wanted to be but maybe uh
couldn't Express themselves in that way
you couldn't be doing
you couldn't be who you are today
probably not if I had stayed in Suburban
Detroit I I don't think so yes
absolutely
so
uh your childhood was was cool
I I wouldn't say it was cool uh I think
everybody has their their own trials and
turbulation growing up but but for me it
was actually it was it was very
difficult you know and um I say that
knowing that other people always have it
worse but um I was never
we were never told you know growing up
that you are or who you want to be you
are worth it it was always kind of like
your your
what somebody else sees you to be here
is my expectations for you you know you
should find somebody get married stay
here raise children and this is what
normal
is and I never saw that for myself
um also
um
so my father
my father had a lot of uh
unrecided issues with
his growing up
um where he was abused and in every
sense of the way by his own father who I
never got to know he passed away before
I was born and I think a lot of those
things trickled
into
how we were raised if that makes sense
um trickled into us and and those own
insecurities that somebody may have for
themselves was put into us so we were
kind of put into a mold I guess you
could say without even really realizing
it because we were
children we didn't we didn't know until
you venture out and actually really try
to find yourself in who you want to be
who you are
you think you're a black sheep because
of something genetic or because of the
environment you the family grew up in I
think a little bit I think it's a little
bit of bold I think I am a black sheep I
think I'm definitely not you know
um your standard
chick by any sons of the word but who
really wants to be
um but
um
let me put it this way I have never met
anybody with an anger problem as strong
as
my father's
out of anybody that I've met so what I
had to do as an adult as a late bloomer
is really say to myself who do I want to
be who do I not want to be I'm not going
to fly off the handle every time I have
a disagreement with another human being
you know I want to actually be a good
person and and
do better in the world no matter what
that might actually be so I think it's a
little bit of a combination New Orleans
is very unique it has been
for over 303 years and beyond that so I
do feel like it it brings a certain type
of person
so I feel like I have that working out
to my advantage here
but then also too how I how I grew up
and how I a way of thinking that I was
taught that I had to tell myself I'm I'm
going to do better than that and in
combination throughout the years I feel
like it made me who I am and I'm still
learning who I am as an individual but
this is my place this is my heart
you're happy here I'm very happy here
that's great it's a fun city very much
so so you are a burlesque performer I am
how did that happen
well
it was always an interest of mine I was
always very into the
um old-timey glamor you're not old
enough to remember when there were
burlesque clubs
I am I remember I grew up in Detroit in
Chicago and I remember so you remember
these things actually there weren't a
lot of them but but they kind of became
replaced with strip clubs yes yes the
strip clubs of today are very very
different than a burlesque club
absolutely absolutely and that's also
kind of what made burlesque kind of like
go Into Obscurity for a while it was
because people were more into the uh
straight up strip clubs they don't want
the idea of what you think you might see
why they want the full monty which is
fine which is totally fine and sometimes
you can get that with a burlesque show
but what I really enjoy is
um
the something that inspires you maybe
it's a movie maybe it's a song maybe
it's a look and then just kind of
completing that in becoming the person
that you were inspired by so it's not so
much about
um
I'm going to take my top off and and
strip in front of somebody which we do
too which is fine
but it's the whole
it's the whole Mystique it's the whole
um idea
of becoming somebody else for that
moment but on the flip side of that you
are still that person that is still you
as an individual your personality is a
much bigger part of your
uh
performance than a strippers
the stripper gets uh
objectified very quickly
and we could adjust we get objectified
too we certainly do
um the thing that I can say is maybe the
difference and it's not it's a big
umbrella too because there's a lot of
burlesque performers who were strippers
for their their main job oh is that
right yeah absolutely you know and then
maybe
um an artistic idea you know they find
or a song you know uh inspires them to
make a whole bit out of it so I can't
say that that one is better than the
other because at the end of the day we
are exposing ourselves in the literal
and figurative sense to make money uh so
so I'm not saying one is better than the
other but this uh burlesque to me has
there's a lot of thought there's a lot
of concentration that goes into what
what you are trying to be perceived as
it's it's by the crowd I imagine it must
be fun to kind of go back in time a
little bit very very fun especially in
this city I mean you look at the
surroundings uh right now we're in the
French Quarter which I call the Spanish
quarter because it's actually not very
French anymore it's very Spanish
so you're inspired by
the cast iron balconies the uh the
street musicians the street artists the
food everything it's it's very
inspiring to create
this because I feel like when people
come here they expect something from
another time a lot of the tourists and
I'm here to provide that for them as
well I don't know that this could be a
burlesque club could exist in other
cities in the U.S
it would kind of be wouldn't be taken
seriously whereas here it seems like it
fits it fits very much so
yes this is
not as old as a European city would be
but we definitely have our history
engraved in us and we're literally
standing on top of it as well
and so it all goes together you've been
doing this for how long
I mean that's for about four and a half
years at this point if I'm not mistaken
uh I started
a couple years before the pandemic and
then of course the pandemic changed
everything but I was trained by uh one
of the mentors that I look up to very
very much her name is Bella blue
if I can say that she had at that time
she had the New Orleans School of
burlesque where you could take an
intensive class
even if you've never had any Dance
Experience it didn't matter if you were
a professional dancer since you were a
child or you've never even danced in
your life didn't matter
so you could learn like an eight-week
um
curriculum where you could learn one
week uh body confidence
um self-expression how your body looks
to others and compared to what you think
you're doing in your own mind really get
a sense of how yourself moves also at
that same time creating a costume
creating an act and to me that was uh
almost kind of like a catalyst
to make me do what I want to do now as a
performer
and how long will your performances go
there's like a series of them throughout
the night
so uh
uh for instance so it was a small show
uh we had two acts each
so uh you would have one act and usually
they last anywhere from around three to
five minutes
you don't want to overstep too much you
don't want to get too over the top you
know and impose on somebody else when
it's their time to do their thing
especially at the smaller gigs but those
are actually really fun too
so three to five minutes and for one uh
my My First Act that I did was what you
see now which is a very traditional
gig kind of hearkening back to like
um the late 20s early 30s when Jazz was
like really in its prime here
so I have that and it's kind of like a
baseline act you know and then the other
one is my my Matador act where I come
out as a matador and you know I'm very
machismo and then like slowly like strip
into being feminine with the long dark
hair and everything so that's
you kind of you do what you want as long
as that covers the bass lines for that
gig and so you're not really mingling
with the crowd after that you're just up
on stage it depends it depends on how I
feel during the night so of course
sometimes you know after if I finished
and I feel like having a couple drinks
or something chatting with friends or
people who came in to see the show
absolutely but other times
I'm just ready to get my money and leave
you know and that's kind of how you you
can't feel like bent out of shape like
if oh she's gotta go okay we get it you
know you gotta gig in the morning and
you're getting topless for these acts
yeah yeah yeah
so nine times out of ten especially in
the quarter
so you can get topless but they want you
to wear pasties
so that's kind of what draws the line to
it's not stripping
but it is stripping uh if you go to uh
Saint Claude Avenue which is my that's
like the new
hot spot in the quarter it's not Bourbon
Street like what you hear about that's
not for the locals that's for the
tourists who've never been here before
uh but Saint Claude Avenue you've got
great spots like the always Lounge the
hi-ho Lounge in
you can be a little more free with
yourself over there I've seen performers
including myself if the ACT is right who
will get totally
butt naked I have never ever ever once
felt like
I felt ashamed of myself or oh my God I
shouldn't have done that or what did I
do ever at any of those places it's a
safe spot it's not like your
um stripping for old dudes with stogies
hanging out of their mouths it's not
that scene at all like this is this is a
safe space our friends are here if
something goes wrong there is somebody
there to like Wrangle that up and make
it so that's not a problem for you
anymore and I love that so much that
Saint Claude Avenue was the first place
that I ever performed
and it's still my favorite
as well but what is this job done for
your self-confidence
it's done a lot for my self-confidence
so when I was still living in Michigan
before I lived in New Orleans
um
I ever since I was a kid I was very
self-conscious very self-conscious I
struggled with weight going up and down
and so by the time I was in my early 20s
my young adulthood I had no idea what I
actually even looked like the mirror
could tell me something but in my mind
it was not what I was seeing there was
something else going on so I wouldn't
even wear
I wouldn't wear a bikini in public I
wouldn't dance the way I wanted to in
public because I was still so insecure
so coming here
and seeing my first burlesque show ever
and I I just saw how
the entertainers were enjoying
themselves and giving the uh the the
clients the the people in the audience
that and and they felt the same as well
it was such a beautiful thing to me
so now I don't get uncomfortable about
taking my clothes off or
showing showing myself having fun while
doing so either it was never ever like a
shameful thing to me like I had always
heard growing up like oh stripping is
shameful only people who hate themselves
do that actually quite the opposite
to me you know so uh it really pushed me
to actually want to perform more and and
want to meet other
performers and get to know my body
better even taking like Health classes
and flexibility classes things that I
would have never done before I I can now
and I
I never ever wanted to be one of those
elderly people
who looks back on their
when they were young and healthy
and and say man I was so insecure wow
did I look good
but I was so insecure
like no I know this now my body is gonna
fall apart one of these days just like
everybody's does you're gonna fall apart
you know you're going to be in and out
of the hospital bedridden
it's what happens to all of us
so at least I can look back at myself
and say
I [ __ ] did that
and hopefully at the end of the day
hopefully somebody owls will be in that
audience or watching me years down the
line or something and say wow you really
helped me feel more comfortable in my
own skin that is the number one thing to
me now if somebody finds me attractive
or somebody wants to [ __ ] me or
something like
I don't really care
to be honest with you I just want like
those other little girls or boys or
whoever who are looking you know who are
feeling insecure
to know like you were fine you were fine
dude
do you dance with any help of alcohol or
drugs or anything like that
I might dance with the help of a drink
or two you know it's to me it's not
drugs I did drugs when I was in my uh
late teens early 20s
when that like super Kush stuff was
really popular that they marketed as
weed which is not weed at all
uh I did that but no in my in my
adulthood I feel like the only one that
I really need is my own self you know
all that confidence like you don't get
that out of a bottle you don't get that
from a drug all of that is fleeting
what's going to stay with you is your
own accomplishments like what did I do
for my own self and I will say this is a
very
this is a Vice City this is a vice city
so people would tell me
when I moved here even before I moved
here when I was talking about moving
here they were like well you know
you moved to New Orleans any advice you
have
that's just gonna amplify like times
three
and I heard it and I was like no I I can
see that and then I actually
lived it
that doesn't help you in the long run
at all it might help you you know in the
time being but I can I let me be the one
to tell you like that does not help you
to get to where you want to be or help
you uh
oh I think it stunts your emotional
growth it's not your emotional growth
absolutely yeah because you're avoiding
you're escaping every
unpleasant emotion
sometimes those unpleasant emotions are
what make us who we are how you grow up
and mature yeah some some emotions are
too difficult for people to deal with
absolutely but for most of us you just
tough it out and you experience it a
hundred times and eventually and this is
life this is where we're all going
through it and we all deal with it in
different ways but
um my first year living I've lived here
uh over six years now so October 18th
was my six year Nola anniversary
the first year that I lived here was uh
actually really difficult because I
didn't I didn't really know anybody here
besides my my very very best friend who
I lived here who I moved here with so
everything else was okay we have a lease
in an apartment so I need a job
I need to be able to pay bills and [ __ ]
just got real right now
so I was drinking a lot I was working I
was taking care of myself but I was also
drinking way more than I should have
been
and uh I I learned very quickly this is
not the route you want to go because
otherwise you're just
wind up
on the on the street you know as as you
see it and that's not
that's not what I wanted to like write
back to friends and family about oh this
is what I got into absolutely not what
have you learned about men from doing
this kind of work
what have I learned about men
um what I've learned about men is for
the most part they see what they want to
see uh
you know if you're out there as a as a
sex object they're going to see with a
sex adject and that's okay that's okay
but
um relationships is is difficult as far
as as that's concerned too have you been
in love before
yes does this job get in the way of that
or is it he could it could almost
enhance it for the right guy it can
almost enhance it I don't feel like it's
hindering me from finding anybody from
being in love with
um I definitely think it's uh it's an
obstacle that they would have to
deal with but also I'm not going to be
changing for anybody else I mean hey I I
left
small town to get away from being
somebody's wife girlfriend you know
mother of their children whatever so I
know that's not for me so if you really
if you really want to get with me then
you have to know me as Roxy the
burlesque performer and Roxy the home
girl walking around the French Quarter
running errands it's the same person
but either way you're still a
non-conformist
I guess so
I guess I would be yeah
yes yes we call it the Island of Misfit
Toys oh that's good
so yeah
what's your favorite thing about New
Orleans
the food
the food is amazing because we have uh
the whole French and Spanish influence
we have the Caribbean influence also the
Native American influence in our
culinary so it's just something so
something very American
that's not necessarily considered
American like you know it's very Niche
to here but like this is what it means
too
being American is because you have all
of these different cultural melting pots
that you hear about throughout the
country but you don't always see you see
it here you hear it here as well with
the music and the in the architecture
and the history it's still as much as a
city has changed and I've not been here
for very long at all I've been here for
about six and over six years you Miss
Katrina
I Miss Katrina I was here for Ida though
but I was not here for Katrina so I
can't
but there's still a very free and
creative Spirit here absolutely I think
it'll be here until the city is no more
you know I really do think that this
city draws in a certain type of
individual kind of like you know Nestles
it
I call the city a lady as well like it's
got a very feminine energy
or
if you're not right it will
push you out as well
what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear
of getting robbed rape and murdered on
the street I mean it's
certainly not the ghost or the
supernatural I'm like afraid of real
life situations and and that's another
thing too is like as glamorous as we may
be on stage or wherever you see us like
we are like those chicks that are
in uh you know in our sweats you know
carry like the the little rolly cart you
know to where cars or what have you so
all the time I have to worry about that
get any regrets in your life anything
you wish you had done I wish I would
have
spoken out more when I was younger and
just been a little more headstrong and
not so meek and also moved sooner
it's not the it's not the worst thing
ever but had I have done that I call
myself a late bloomer
so right now I'm 33 years old
but if I would have done this when I was
23 I feel like I would have even been
more self-realized than I am right now
and Roxy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important lesson I've
learned is don't let anybody else tell
you who you are
or what you're capable of
you have to find that in your own selfie
we're we are not who somebody else
tells us we are I I thought that for a
very long time and as soon as I got over
that [ __ ] I was like no I am Roxy I
am me I am going to do whatever I want
to do I don't care what anybody else
says family members loved ones whatever
like
you're still gonna love me even if I do
it so
um don't let anybody else tell you who
you are as an individual I feel like a
lot of us fall victim to that and want
to live up to somebody else's
expectations be it a family member or
somebody that we look up to very much a
loved one you are your own person
that's excellent
Roxy thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you so much great talk thank
you very much yes absolutely